hey guys welcome back to brand new video
Rebecca I'm Borderlands 3 today and
today we're gonna be talking about a
little bit of the new bloody harvest
event it's gonna be going live somewhere
around October we'll get into these
specifics and stuff like that throughout
this whole entire video we got all the
details that were shown on the
borderlands show that just went live
about like an hour ago so I'm going to
be recording this after it's finished
you know all that good stuff so as I
look to be if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new and let's get started it's
gonna be going live in October obviously
around the end of October as they said
and it will start with a whole new
mission there's gonna be new weapons new
shields grenade mods trinkets skins and
loads more of course as expected I would
hope that that would be a thing and I'm
glad they can confirm that that's really
really cool on top of that there's going
to be a new debuff called terror this is
going to affect your sway and accuracy
drastically one effected some of the new
gear is gonna have anointed perks that
can actually help you with this and
decrease the how much it is affecting
you so it's not too much of a sway but
some of the gear can actually turn that
terror against the enemies as well which
is really [ __ ] cool this quest is
good to start with a guy named Maurice I
believe that's his name Maurice Morsi
morsi's something like that he is a
talking saurian on sanctuary not really
sure how this fits in he's gonna be on
the ship when it starts so the day that
the bloody harvest event goes live
Maurice Murr whatever his name happens
to be this Orion is gonna be chilling on
sanctuary you're gonna talk to him
that's how you're going to be getting a
lot of your DLC content they said so
just make sure to definitely talk to him
a lot the event is going to be lasting
about a month and a half so if we
presume that it's going to start at
let's say October 31st we have probably
until midway through December to finish
this now they're probably going to be
loads more content the Mellow on take
down will probably be out in the middle
of this and then the DLC so I don't know
once again we don't know the specific
date but that's just my interpretation
of it and always since that means that
we only have a month and a half of time
that means that is all limited stuff
hopefully this it won't be taking too
long gonna be talking about that a
little bit more later in the video of
course but hopefully if I do get to beat
it very quickly and all that good stuff
I'll have a video out showing about how
to get all that new stuff the quickest
there's got to be some type of legendary
farm going on we all want the new stuff
there's apparently going to be a new
boss called the captain
haunt this is a more of a play on words
of truant if you know who truant is you
understand what's going to be happening
some enemies in the area will now be
haunted when haunted and killed they
spawn of ghosts that attack the player
very very interesting there according to
the developers this the new main mission
could take about two to three hours
adding more time if you could do side
quests you roughly could probably finish
this within the day so that'd be pretty
cool and they also gave out a shift code
I'm really really hoping I didn't [ __ ]
this up I copy and pasted it from
somebody in the stream chat because they
showed that thing for like five seconds
I wasn't able to check it but I'll paste
up the code here on screen and I'll
probably put it in the description as
well so you can copy and paste that if
you need to do that you can keep it in
going to your shift on the Borderlands
game and plug in the shift code there
get some golden keys unsure how many
there are but that's roughly what the
shift code is gonna do I think it's
golden keys the one thing though about
the code is that you have until I
believe September 24th so you have
roughly the weekend I believe to plug
this in so if you are watching this the
day this goes live the day after you'll
be all good to plug that in but I
believe you only have a couple days to
plug in so definitely hurry up and get
that as soon as possible definitely do
it if you have some time I guess
according to the developers you do
actually have to plug this in game and
not at the website this is like past me
after I'm editing this video and stuff
so you might have to actually go in game
to plug that in hey guys it's gonna be
the end of 8a hope you guys did enjoy it
Luminator thoughts on bloody harvest so
far I mean just from all the information
that we've been hearing it seems pretty
nice I hope it's it seems like one of
those headhunter missions that takes
like 2 hours to beat and that's really
about it which I mean I'm totally cool
with they're just better be enough
content to keep us active until you know
Mallett 1 takedown comes out but that's
really just my thought so as always like
to be if you do enjoy guys subscribe if
you're new I'll see you guys later take
care peace out you know all that good
stuff bye bye
[Music]
you